would you ever consider an oasis reunion
I know you would without doubt that's my
band I mean without a doubt but we've
got become brothers first I think you
know I mean before we start talking
about music once if we want to start
liking each other
inevitably I think the next step would
be to take the band out for a little
spin around the block
sure why not why not people want it you
know I mean and I like I love Oasis oh
he's the best thing ever you like
Twitter right you tweet a lot yeah I
love Twitter and most of your Twitter
about your brother being a jerk a potato
a potato yeah the word potato can you is
I need a bit of a translation but you
know a potato is knowing I know what a
bit like a physical every time I just
see a couple of pictures of Emily just I
just see a potato
oh maybe the way we wait Nick brain is
wired and I just got this little potato
driving our kid yeah yeah and you see a
picture and you'll put the word potato
under yeah pouting potato angry potatoes
I need to follow you I don't follow you
on twitter I don't got stalker potato
when you guys are now bono starker
potato you know I mean oh you must be
driving him nuts oh I am hey [ __ ] you
tighten even more I got no one album oh
my god
thank God I don't have a brother